for a weightlifter if they don't snatch
and clean and jerk well well their
identity is now missing so they're going
to snatch and clean a jerk well and
they're gonna do whatever it takes to do
that CrossFitters can get theirs in the
gym in so many different ways so in all
places to hide as a cross yeah yeah but
when you're taking your shirt off and
you're wearing your hot pants
you can't hide right and so for them
it's like I'm gonna get my nutrition
locked in I'm not gonna go party on the
weekends I am going to get enough sleep
you know there's the recovery aspect
that I really do feel like CrossFitters
work on really really hard compared to
power lifters oh maybe maybe we losers
talk to me about what your favorite
pre-workout drink is what's your
pre-workout of choice I love caffeine so
like you know there's do you know who
Omar Esau is no he's a he's a he's kind
of easy youtuber he actually does have a
lot of good knowledge around fitness and
you know strength and culture and stuff
like that and his product is called Arab
eros or Ouroboros and it's it's really
like clean it's there's only like five
ingredients you know it's like caffeine
creatine beta-alanine like the five core
ingredients to a pre-workout and it's
only 200 milligrams of caffeine now you
should try to take that half hour before
training and then I I like to have a
relatively kind of empty stomach before
I take my pre-workout so I sometimes I
will wake up and you know I might have
like I always drink like a green drink
to get my greens in and then I might
just like take my pre-workout and go to
the gym like without anything in my
stomach but if I'm gonna train them a
little bit later like say like 2 3 4
p.m. I'll have oats
or like some sort of carb and then I'll
just chill for like two hours and then
go I will never really sometimes I guess
I'll have like scrambled eggs too cause
like for me it's really hard to get all
of my protein in per day so if I'm not
eating protein for you know for the
hours of the day or five hours a day and
then I go to the gym and I come back now
I'm in this huge kind of hole where I
have to get back on the project it's a
never-ending treadmill of trying to eat
so everyone that's listening that's got
a diet that requires them to have high
volumes of protein in mine at the moment
my cows are like I think 210 210 grams
of protein per day which is like
ridiculous but I'd say it's like
moderate moderate high for someone who's
like in 80 kilos range and um falkland
like you right if you get to TM and
you've not had any protein yet like
that's gonna be exaggerated or the day
is gonna suck bad yeah I mean I do like
to Train an empty stomach ideal world
you know like or having a big meal and
then chilling letting it all digest and
then going to the gym I'm not a believer
in like eating a pre-workout meal I
don't like I don't think that that's I
think that's kind of like bro sciency
type stuff and then yeah I just do
caffeine and then after you know I'm I
have to you know sometimes I want to get
250 to 270 grams of protein because of
my body weight and like I have to have
two or three shakes you know a day just
because I can't I don't like eating that
much like chicken breast and and meat
but I do actually notice the difference
on high protein like I really really do
I know just fit physique wise like yeah
I don't I don't and that's something
that I don't really care too much about
but it's nice to have you know it as a
weight lifter your you know your primary
focus is to be healthy and in shape so
that you can perform what you need to
perform
it's not about aesthetics but I know
that that if your aesthetics are right
there's a chance that your body
composition
right and therefore you're maximizing
your weight class or if that makes sense
you know if you you have too much body
fat it's too much weight for your weight
class that is not usable and so
something I've noticed on like a very
high protein diet is that I can be a
little bit more sloppy if that makes
sense in in you know in the way that I
eat but that's a big stipulation that's
a big thing to do to try to get enough
protein because if you want to get
enough protein and eat poorly it's not
gonna happen you know if you want to eat
enough protein and go to you know
McDonald's or Taco Bell like you're
gonna get really fat or whatever but eat
enough protein then you don't have to
count your macros as hard or be as
diligent but there's no there's no cheat
meal that's high in protein
no one's nope oh I'm really know what
actually a one that's really surprising
and like
this is one of my things about junk food
and cheat meals is like I don't really
like them unless they have high protein
and at that point they end up having
super high calories if that makes sense
what like so like chicken wings okay
a chicken wings actually as far as like
a cheat meal goes there the macros are
fantastic high in protein relatively low
in calorie compared to you know pizza
like pizza legitimately has nothing in
it but calories and fat so those two
being cheat meals are not the same in
the same ballpark yeah in my opinion but
you still get to relinquish your diet
feel like you're not super restricted
and you get like that the take that box
you take that I let my diet go a little
bit box but in one version of the world
you've just put what maybe like 800
grams of carbs and another 150 grams of
fat probably I see yourself with a pizza
versus like yeah I don't know what with
with with chicken wings but it's it's
something that or a burger right a
burger compared to a pizza those should
not be in the same ballpark pizzas
should be closer to ice cream you know
but anyways that the main point being is
that high protein is not easy but it
does help a lot especially for someone
like me where I'm constantly worried
about my recovery constantly worried so
like go in and do a bodybuilding workout
I don't want that to affect my mobility
in my shoulders my hips knees ankles
joints that need to be very very loose
and protected I don't I don't want to go
in to the gym and have to do
bodybuilding even though I love it you
know what I mean
so it's nice to have to be able to head
do a high protein diet and and minimize
body fat like that yeah and also given
two versions of the world given like one
version Zac makes weight for the
competition and hits all of his lifts
gets nine white lights and all that
stuff and in another version the world
that happens but with ABS
it's like I'll take the world the huzzah
well it's yeah yeah yes although you
know it's never been about like lifting
well and and performing well is always
gonna Trump the way that I look but
there's that there's actually a famous
track a world-famous track coach here at
in College Station which is where I live
Texas A&M track coach and he's like at a
certain point you know we have to look
at body composition because if we're
maximizing every bit of an athlete's
potential they need to have as much
usable muscle as possible and if you
have extra fat additional fat that's
that's space and that's weight that's
added weight to our sport which is just
speed you know it's all about who's the
fastest who can maintain the speed the
longest who's you know lightest but also
the most powerful so yeah its body
composition does matter but it's a very
fine line I mean I again I've never
really used to think about I need
protein I need protein but it really
really does make a difference when you
start to eat like that it's kind of like
very similar to that bodybuilding type
of lifestyle that bro lifestyle you have
to um there's no one who accidentally
falls into a high protein diet either
you know like no right no one just ends
up going back through a year of macros
which they weren't tracking which they
weren't counting but we're tracking and
goes oh would you look at that I just
happened by product if my diet was 200
grams of protein it's like yeah no I
think that would be a way to force that
down in one for me yeah I think this
suggested for someone who's 80 kilos is
what 140 program protein that's super
easy but you know we're looking for you
if you're you know you're trying to
build muscle or whatever you might go
all the way up to 250 and so that yeah
it's just not possible yeah so we've
touched on a number of different
categories of strength athletes or
endurance athlete whatever it is I
thought it might be fun today for me and
you to go through some of the scenario
types of different lifters and different
athletes that we see in the gym or that
we see online and stuff like that so to
hold my hands up for the different teams
that I'm on I probably came into the
world as a bro lifter actually
originally before that a cricketer which
is like British version of a baseball I
guess right and then bro lifter
bodybuilder a little bit of sort of
white eye and boxing and stuff and then
now CrossFit what's your what's your
heritage in strength and stuff like that
yeah it was for football for American
football was the first time I was
introduced to the weight room I was
about 13 or 14 and it was just all bro
stuff and then when when I was actually
on a program we would do big compound
movement squats bench pull-ups you know
it was actually interesting I couldn't I
could probably do like maybe one or two
pull-ups when I graduated high school I
was 18 years old I was just so long and
you know living didn't ya just very
looming me and then I got to college and
I was playing lacrosse at the University
University of Vermont and we had a very
structured weightlifting program or like
'wait program and you know we would go
four times a week and that's where like
my strength coach was basically like oh
you can't do a pull-up you're gonna do
them every day you know every day at
least when you come in here when you're
fresh just try to get you know whatever
you can and by the end of that I think I
got like 15 and I that was the biggest
difference in like my physique that I've
ever noticed outside of actually my legs
from squatting - we would squat two
three times a week and that was
noticeable as well so that was my big
exposure to training and then when I
graduated college I felt that I still
had a lot of I still had a lot of
ability remaining so you
I didn't know how to lacrosse was done
for me so like pretty much all sports
like official sports that I used to
partake in like American football
basketball lacrosse like you know I
could have done like house leagues or
things like that but I wanted to get I
wanted to save very intense and train
really hard and I actually I saw an
article it might have been unlike Men's
Journal or something and it was on rich
Froning
you know in mine it might not have even
been on rich Froning but it was about
Murph the workout Murph and which is a
you know of staple in CrossFit these
days and I remember being like wow
that's what a weird way of thinking of
training you know here's a bunch of reps
do them as fast as you can
and there are there things that like you
know push-ups pull-ups squats those are
things that I've only ever done in sets
of 10 and you know with rest and on a
program and I was like that sounds
really really cool so I went into a gym
across the gym and then I fell in love
with it there and then I got really just
more and more sucked into it I wanted to
coach more people I wanted to help out
so I got my level one and then I got my
USA weightlifting certification so USA
w's level 1 certification and then I was
lucky enough to get a full-time coaching
job as a crossfitter or as a CrossFit
coach which in America are anywhere
really full-time like getting a wage to
be a CrossFit coach is a pretty good
deal and I think a lot of my development
as a coach to that job but then after a
while I kind of I didn't want to work
with kind of your average Joes anymore
and that wasn't
the main reasoning behind that was I was
tired of of people teaching people and
giving my all teaching them how to
snatch and clean the jerk and do all
these movements to have them just want
to look better you know I really wanted
performance and so what I did was I went
back to the collegiate strength
conditioning field I was an intern for
free which is crazy that's one of the
things that you have to do when you want
to be a strength coach at least in
America is that you have to intern and
that means it's pretty much a volunteer
position I was doing that for seven or
eight months and then I got another job
in Texas A&M which is here in College
Station and and since then since that
point I've fallen back into
weightlifting throughout all of that
that whole thing where I graduated
college - now I've been weight lifting
in and out of being involved in CrossFit
and might say the last two and a half
three years have been like pure
weightlifting but I had you know I've
been coaching weightlifting I've been
coaching the lifts I've been competing
and we lifting since 2013 so that's kind
of the broad picture of my training
30,000 foot view of your Athiya
background it's so funny about the when
you want to go and do something that is
focused on finding the best people or
getting to the toward the top or the
peak of people's performance I'm
reminded of Ryan holiday do you know how
he started his writing career out so he
went and assisted Robert Greene five
times New York Times bestselling author
mastery 48 laws of power all that stuff
and previous modern wisdom guests went
and assisted him for free as a research
a research assistant and you know you
got Robert Greene right in these huge
books drawing on 3,000 years worth of
history and Orion I need to find out
about where Julius Caesar's this this
thing happened can you [ __ ] after the
library and go and sort it for me and he
just did that but then you get coming
out the other side of that you get this
ridiculous experience and that
presumably is the same for you getting
to work at
it's such an incredible level and then
you can distill that back down
yeah like working at collegiate strength
and conditioning and I know that you
like there I'm sure there's a lot of
Americans that listen but if you're you
know European or elsewhere in the world
like it is a big big deal in America
especially at a place like Texas A&M
which is a sixty thousand student
university sixty thousand students
undergrad like that's the the level and
the amount of money that comes in to
this to sporting here is like it's
something you would compare to a major
football club in the English Premier
League like it's it's seriously that
intense our stadium right over there it
houses a hundred one hundred and ten
thousand fans so when you go see one of
those games you saying yeah so a lot of
people want to be strength coaches
because they have their these these
really prominent programs and so it's a
very saturated market but the process is
you know you have to be an intern you
have to build your way up and then
hopefully by its kind of yes and that is
for the most part at least my experience
it was for free what I did I felt like
you know I was competing in
weightlifting you know in and out and
then I i had like what you would call
like a fellowship program at Texas A&M
where I was actually being paid and it
was kind of nice
once that finished up I kind of wanted
to just take a break and and focus on
weightlifting and and trying to be a
better and maybe going into private I
didn't really know what I wanted to do
with my life but I knew that the the
lineage that it seemed very bureaucratic
to to be involved in something like like
that you know and I feel like I'm maybe
more of a creative person than it just
might not have been the best fit for me
and so I remember my next job after that
because I needed to make money was a
personal trainer at a gold
and it was actually I would have loved
to have seen that yeah and it was
actually uh not a bad gig man like it
really was it was pretty cool and there
was actually some pretty knowledgeable
people there and making good money and
for me it wasn't a means it was it
wasn't like oh I'm gonna be a Gold's Gym
personal trainer for the rest of my life
you know I'm gonna figure out the next
step but right now it's pretty good you
know I'm in a cheaper place a cheaper
cost of living area a lot of stuff is
going good in my life so someone
actually mentioned like hey you should
check out YouTube for like putting your
stuff on YouTube and so I didn't really
know what the purpose of YouTube was
like I literally thought it was just a
place where you could like send links to
other people like you would just said
you know and watch I didn't know that
people had channels where they would
kind of use it as this social outlet it
wasn't like a community type thing and
then when this person showed me like
they showed me Casey nice tat they
showed me some of like the bigger names
like god I can't david dobrik and stuff
like that I was like wow this is this
culture is crazy like I had no idea you
know it's like I I felt like I was blind
to it I just wasn't paying attention or
something like that so I would just
consume that content all the time then I
I made some videos around my training
for CrossFit and I remember like because
I I when I went to school I was a film
and television Studies major and then
like a business minor and I remember
like being really really into editing
and like loving film production that's
why I wanted to do it so when I made
these vlogs of my training for CrossFit
CrossFit it was like it would take me a
long time I would I would make these
like really serious edits and then I
would put them on YouTube and no one
watched them and I remember I posted one
to a CrossFit page or the CrossFit
reddit page and some guy was like listen
not that you're not that good-looking
you're not that good at CrossFit right
and you're not telling us like anything
about your story
or and you don't have any expertise and
I was like well first off I'm not that
bad-looking wait no I you know I took
that I was like kind of like you know
[ __ ] this guy he doesn't know anything
but then also I was like well that's
true my videos were all very surface
level just had nothing to them I think
it was because I was trying to cater to
what KC nice that had already
established himself as you know people
who were involved in his story before
the content that I saw people were not
involved in my story people don't know
who the [ __ ] I am so one thing the guy
said it's like do you have any expertise
and I said hell yeah I mean I I have a
lot of expertise in weightlifting so my
next video
I completely revamped I was like you
know what I see this issue in the snatch
and here's how you fix it here's the
issue being played out and I'll show an
example here's what it should look like
and here are the drills you can do to
fix it thank you guys for watching
boom send it out I deleted my other
YouTube vlogs I clicked the link to this
copy paste it put it put it on reddit
weightlifting and they loved it everyone
in that in in the reddit community was
like this is awesome man keep doing it
and so I I basically was like okay I'll
do another one next week because I have
another idea
and that one did well and I just
repeated that for now two and a half
three years and I've got 103 thousand
subscribers and it was really
interesting how that all played out it
was like it seemed so intuitive and so
natural to just put what you know out
there and if someone likes it somewhere
there's a chance that maybe someone else
might like it and it might snowball from
there
but you can't give yourself the benefit
of the doubt if you try to do something
that you're not or if you try to do what
other people are doing
so I have been talking about this a lot
recently which is your weirdness is your
superpower so the unique offering that
you have to put out or that I have to
power or anybody that's listening has
that is your USP because no one
literally no one else on the planet even
a twin brother or a twin sister has
precisely the same mix of life
experiences and interests and talents
and proclivities and background story in
all the rest of it no one nobody else
has that so when you see people that are
prepared to dilute down their unique
individual offering or as you say kind
of perhaps aim for or align themselves
with some externalized idea of what they
should be doing oh well this is what the
other guys are doing maybe I'll just try
and do a carbon copy of that and maybe
that is you if that's your true like you
speaking your truth or then gray if you
are just like a miniature Casey Neistat
then [ __ ] front like great for you
yeah but if you're not you're losing out
on the opportunity to really break it
through and you hit the nail on the head
there if you find it interesting you
have to presume like you're not an alien
think you are an alien from outer space
you know like if you find it interesting
the like there has to be at least a
couple of other people out there that
find interesting and therefore that
might roll even further forward and
that's yeah you know part of my that was
my mindset and that was actually what
has provided me with the most amount of
successes that the organic growth from
when I started to now has been amazing
you know I had at one point I had 20,000
subscribers and I was getting 20,000
views it was like anyone anyone who's
been a YouTube channel that is that's
stupid yeah because it was a lot of
people weren't subscribing so I would
get a lot of clicks from elsewhere but
it was like the people who were
following me the people who wanted to
listen to me I was putting it directly
at them and I were
not backing down I was not changing at
all and it just it kept working and I
you know I would put in so much goddamn
time on these videos and I loved every
second of it I would sit down and edit
for 40 hours like like straight up I
would do you know twelve hours one day
and then I would do like six hours the
next and it would it would just be like
till like 3:00 in the morning I just
didn't care it was so awesome cuz then
when I got to click upload and I could
see people view and comment and talk
about it it was like man you know I'm
I'm actually doing something with my
life and I was not prepared to let that
slip at all and people when I started it
I was like yeah you know I've got like a
thousand subscribers people like oh
that's cool but it's like what is that
YouTube subscribers what does that even
mean you know like my parents were like
okay well you brought you probably
should like get a career going yes
that's nice it's like that's nice yeah
and and you know now it's like okay when
you look at what marketing agencies want
I actually when I graduated I got a job
in advertising right away and the value
of a hundred and three thousand
subscriptions and the value of all of
these things of this consumption of your
media is so huge it's so it cannot be
understated how valuable that is in
today's society and yet when people are
starting to try it and build something
of value like that they're like hey
you're being an idiot go do a real job
like how are we still in that realm of
people discouraging people from doing
creative [ __ ] when the it's the creative
[ __ ] that actually provides the most
value
I mean like like I have a video with
three million views on Lu Xiaojun okay
my favorite video of yours man
right and that three million views like
what cable what cable television show
can knock out three million views on
just a regular show they [ __ ] can't
and how much money do they spend to do
that not have you seen it's very recent
Eric Weinstein on Joe Rogan the motion
one yeah most recent one say he only
like what I do is I look at the clips
but I liked some of the stuff that so
you know you've watched the clip of the
bit that I'm about to talk about now but
it's where he talks about traditional
media versus mainstream media no I
haven't seen that no dude you've got to
go find it cuz it you would absolutely
love it so basically Eric Weinstein
people who don't know he is this
absolute freak genius polymath guy who
is on Rogen all the time super clever
mathematician managing director at teal
capital like Peter Thiel PayPal mafia
guy anyway huge penis massive massive
massive dick guy and he is talking to
Joe Rogan about the problem of when two
different worlds collide and he's
talking about kind of this new world
which is the Joe Rogan's the xacti
Landers the modern wisdoms of the world
kind of the the subculture of Internet
stuff when it clashes with the older
world the ABC the NBC the BBC the ITV
stuff in the UK and what he says is
Rogen brings up this brilliant point
where he said people talk about
mainstream media and they use that as a
signal that this is the media that has
the most credibility it's the one that
has the best experts it's the whites
it's the one and everything else is like
a guy in his bedroom doing a thing which
you know yeah I don't have a massive
amount of a capability to complain about
but and the argument that gets made by
Eric is perfect and he says well hang in
a second like if you put this podcast
out and this podcast gets five million
views yeah I mean a simple math and
I've 5 million views not only 5 million
views but 5 million views multiplied by
probably I wouldn't like to guess what
the average watch time on Rogen's
channel is but it'll be like probably 30
minutes maybe more maybe like 40 45
minutes probably or something some read
it to you you'll be freakish like the
time and attention that people are
spending watching wrote so he's that
what hang on a second if I get more
watch time on this channel then ABC NBC
ITV BBC who's mainstream media yeah he
has mainstream media now there's
traditional media traditional media's
that mainstream media I don't think so I
like right and when Joe had the
epidemiologist on his show when it was
about four weeks ago when the
coronavirus scare was beginning that's
where I got my information that's where
I got everything was the professional
epidemiologist who was as clear-cut and
as dry as it could possibly be
there was zero entertainment value none
of it there's no editing it was a guy in
a room talking to another guy about what
the [ __ ] is happening that to me was
like oh finally thank you thank you
after this disease or this virus has
been out in in China and it was dude it
was going on in January and I remember
people being like there was some memes
being made and then then it was like a
[ __ ] it you know it's in Wuhan no one
really cares you know like I remember
that we I had practice
I mean weightlifting practice and all my
my lifters are students at Texas A&M you
know they're college kids they weren't
even giving a [ __ ] no one gave a [ __ ]
about this thing and it was mainly
because no one knew anything like you we
could have figured this out like we
could have just been more informed
earlier on and what was amazing was I
still wasn't informed at all I had a
semi
to seminars one of them was gonna be
last week in Maine so I would have to
take a flight there's no way yeah but
when I saw this epidemiologist or I
think it was like a very viral thing
yeah yeah I saw him
it was super clear-cut super dry it told
me exactly what I need to know what's
probably gonna happen you know we
thought why this is so bad we're [ __ ]
all this stuff and it he told me and it
was good instead of Donald Trump being
like you know where we have the most
tremendous scientists you know
everything is the best we're you know
it's not a big deal like so just tell us
just tell us what the [ __ ] is going on
and I'll be on my way
well here's the thing here's the thing
is well about the mainstream media I'm
gonna reprogram myself to say like the
traditional media this learn about
traditional media when they have these
panel shows first off you it's it's a
cliche now to talk about you know you
get your 30-second spot and you're
trying to get a zinger in so it's a good
YouTube video like that old what I think
is more interesting is people presume
that a large lineup of guests equals a
high amount of value it's like oh we'll
look at this
they've got Ben Affleck and Sam Harris
on the same show and it's bill maher
show they've got this guy he's a
virologist and this woman she's public
health official and this guy and you're
like right I know that sounds great that
sounds fantastic but it's the it's the
girl who has played hard to get for ages
with big titties that doesn't care about
having sex with you it's like all of
this stuff all of the headlines sound
fantastic but the actual performance and
what you get out of it and completely
terrible yeah yes it's it's always been
when we've privatized something that
shouldn't be privatized so we have
privatized media or or we've privatized
news that makes zero sense news is
public that's the definition of it it's
delivering events things that have
happened ways to protect yourself all of
these different things and we've
privatized that so people make money so
there was a I just saw this goddamn clip
man and this woman was like we're
working on a vaccine we're working on
vaccine so we go to this company and
it's like this is like ABC right we're
gonna vaccine and then they talk to them
the lead scientist of this vaccine and
they're like we talked to the lead
scientist who's making this vaccine on
the floor and then the person's like
yeah we're ready to like make the
vaccine and they're like and back to you
it was like I'm not you clean you 10
seconds was like are you kidding me I
would have sat there and listened this
person talked for 30 minutes I'm not
allowed to leave my [ __ ] house and
you guys are still making for minute
long clips where the the lead scientist
making a vaccination that could save
millions of lives is now being [ __ ]
pigeon holed into a 10-second bit so you
can try and get more views like that why
are we in that world it's there's it's
no wonder why people give more of a [ __ ]
about Joe Rogan where he sits down with
guys for three hours and he's like huh
interesting you know like I just
remember being absolutely floored after
that you know and it's the same old song
and dance it happens every time as bad
as it is the advantage for as long as
that game continues to be played by
traditional media there is a gap in the
market for people like me people like
you people that rogen people at Eric
Weinstein you know because it's not
being serviced and the fact it's like
the stats again it's cliche to say but I
think podcasts that's essentially double
it's like the Moore's law that every two
years they're doubling the the total
number of global listens yeah and some
unbeliever it's like more than 50% of
Americans are now subscribed to a
podcast now that doesn't mean they're
necessarily listen every week but that's
like okay like there's not more than 50%
of Americans that do pretty much
anything anything yeah yeah there's
nothing that unites yo you can't even
get 50% of the country to vote together
like well it's it's when when social
media becomes me
you know it's like having a YouTube
channel is becoming more and more social
media like having a YouTube channel and
getting people to watch is very
different than having an Instagram and
getting people to to follow but those
sort of things are more blending more
and more together if you have a podcast
there's a chance that you'll have a
YouTube channel and there's a chance
that you'll be able to clip up some of
those YouTube channel podcast clips and
throw them on your Instagram so the more
and more connected it is and and the
more and more people are going to
consume that style of media rather than
your typical ABC but if to bring it back
to - powerlifting weightlifting
bodybuilding you know all different
forms of fitness there I imagine that
the the viewership for those things is
doubling the viewership and the
listening to all of those things is
doubling as well
there is definitely definitely a lot
more room for legitimate sources of
information around fitness and I think
there always will be
people think it's getting too saturated
it's not it's when a certain trend kicks
off and then other people just latch on
to that trend right
I think Jeff Nippert pulling in
scientific examples of why things work
and trying to lay them out in simplistic
ways like that is becoming a more
saturated style of delivering content
even though it's not wrong and if you do
it you're not really it it all depends
on the person who's delivering if I say
hey you know Jeff Nippert is doing this
I want to do it well then that's
probably the wrong approach but if I say
here's something that I'm really
passionate about and here's someone who
does it pretty well I think I'm gonna
try to do a little bit what they do use
a little bit of influence I think that's
okay but there is always room for more
information around fitness I mean look
at where we are from when you started
and when I started weightlifting and
and just going to the gym look at the
the knowledge that the average gym goer
has compared to then well you don't have
to
you're not trolling through
bodybuilding.com forums that's what I
used to do many nation whistles that is
literally what I used to do I mean I was
around when dial-up internet was the
thing you know I mean I was and kids
these days I'll never know exactly yes
these days we'll never know
yeah anything Craig Ritchie and sunny
Webster giving you free [ __ ] workouts
all the time
yeah are the best information on the
planet available free streaming in full
HD v our 3d [ __ ] no it's actually
crazy man like I can you know if someone
wants to learn to snatch and clean a
jerk like they can go online and [ __ ]
do it and that is crazy if I want to go
and learn how to surf if I want to do
anything I can do it it's it's amazing
it also people are still too lazy
sometimes to do that you know you'll go
to a Globo gym and you'll see someone
squatting with [ __ ] form and it'll be
amazing to you that someone will be
squatting with such [ __ ] for more [ __ ]
technique and they'll be adding more and
more weight and they'll be just lifting
like a general jackass when we do have
all of these awesome
you know sources of information so a lot
of times it's more of like a human
condition like yes the information is
getting better it's better and better
better but a lot of times you see humans
are lazy sacks of [ __ ]
puffs least resistance money always is
so look let's let's get into it right
let's start because I've got a
powerlifter who's one of the guys that
comes on in co-hosts now and then Johnny
definitely there is a disproportionate
number of power lifters who are also
accountants what percent weird try and
tell me otherwise that's super weird
yeah I don't know I've never I've never
met I don't think I've met a power
lifter that's an accountant well um um
they love spreadsheets you know
everything's get coded that's actually
true I mean about now that I think about
the powerlifting coach that I know who
owns my gym when we had a gym the good
old days his program is insanely it's
it's like so deep you know it's got
beautiful pages of spreadsheets
color-coded all that all that jazz yeah
yeah yes so power lifters power lifters
a lot of them are accountants
I think weight lifters in my experience
weight lifters are kind of like they're
a little bit like the RT kid in school
like you probably they probably did like
music probably didn't music I reckon
going through school perhaps did maybe
even like a little bit of you like dance
or something I mean look you're you want
to see and there's my drum set right
here Mon I got it I got it I'm telling
you yeah okay so the power lifters are
definitely the kids who got A's in math
and are very hardworking I think there's
another there's another wing of the
power lifters and they are the kids that
listen to Slipknot Metallica like a lot
of heavy metal as what's yourselves the
guy that does the bro science YouTube
channel I can't remember his name but he
says they were the kids at the back of
the class that were playing buddy bloody
knuckles and pacing themselves with same
bloody knuckles at the back of the class
Pierce and his safety pins like there
are those - those are the two main camps
I think yes so there would be meatheads
and nerds
yeah yeah but both both of whom have
realized that if they live
tons of whites it's kind of impressive
yeah like yeah I know what you're saying
and then I'd say weight lifters are more
inclined to be kind of artsy I guess too
if we're gonna if we're gonna group them
into like click click II type things or
groups in high school I would say it's
hard to it's hard because you could say
that CrossFitters there's a group of
them that are kind of nerdy hard workers
but they also some CrossFitters like I
feel like some of the CrossFit girls
could be the like attractive girl who
was also had a 4.0 and was a part of a
bunch of different clubs oh yeah you
know hi super good eater of domains yeah
but there's also there is also a huge
huge subculture of CrossFit girls who
have realized that they can wear hot
pants year-round if they do CrossFit yes
look yeah aryen i usually get shouted
out off my mum when i walk out wearing
no shorts but you're telling me that i
can do that an hour a day five days a
week in this gym even serious yeah
that's absolutely for under bra Wow like
that's and you know who you are okay you
know who you are yeah I think you know
something I'm always thinking about is
like the things the recovery I think
that CrossFitters are but it's much more
a part of their culture to focus on
recovery at all levels and focus on
nutrition at all levels if you're like
really really into it
because there are so many different
movements I feel like the training is
like when you go to the gym there's so
many different movements so you can't
necessarily train or control the way
that you move and everything and so it's
almost a release it's like a relief of
pressure if that makes sense like if if
for a weightlifter if they don't snatch
and clean and jerk well well their
identity is now missing so they're going
to snatch and clean it jerk well and
they're gonna do whatever it takes to do
that CrossFitters can get theirs in the
gym they can get theirs in the gym it in
so many different ways so in all places
to hide as a cross yeah yeah but when
you're when you're taking your shirt off
and you're wearing your hot pants
you can't hide right and so for them
it's like I'm gonna get my nutrition
locked in I'm not gonna go party on the
weekends I am going to get enough sleep
you know there's the recovery aspect
that I think across by I really do feel
like we're caught CrossFitters work on
really really really hard compared to
power lifters or maybe maybe weight
lifters doesn't there's another one
actually as well I don't know so much
about weight lifters because I'm not
watched the sessions quite so closely
but I know for an absolute fact that
powerlifting has to be the least time
efficient sport to train in ya ever
known well that is true but it's mainly
again that's a path of least resistance
there if you you watch power lifters
they so weight lifters we sit down a lot
when we're training but at the same time
the relative loads that were lifting are
nowhere near as high as power lifters so
we can get up and go lift again like we
you know sometimes you start having
conversations and not losing focus but
power lifters it's like they just killed
themselves in their last set so they're
gonna rest and then that rest turns into
something that's like 10 minutes long a
lot of phone use yes using the next
track yes yeah yes so I
things though weightlifters do that
quite a bit and everyone Swan when I'm
coaching I have to get on my weight
lifters asses to be like hey we're
training now like let's go you know
that's one of the things especially to
fly the flag at least in part for
CrossFit because we're just we're just
kind of back but you never run in the
moment to fly the flag at least in part
for CrossFit I like the fact that is a
part of your day where your phone is
left in your back you know you could
yeah white board out your right workout
on your whiteboard foam goes in bag
there's a clock on the wall that's it
done but especially as a weightlifter
because of the requirement now this 21st
century requirement with weight lifters
and power lifters especially those that
are getting remote coaching to video
every one of their lifts and then they
go over they take the phone off the
little gob grip that's attached to the
rig on the far side they watch the video
back then they choose the next track
then they get sucked into Instagram on
Instagram story or pod yes on the other
you know abscess vicious cycle it's yeah
that when I coach my guys it's kind of a
thing where I just they don't they're
not allowed to have their cell phones
out so and that just everyone's focused
on each other focus on themselves focus
on the barbell and then you know you can
when we go to do accessories you can
bring your phone and chat and stuff I
don't care too much but for the most
part I try to limit the phone usage
completely during practice times because
it's not helping anyone
you know something and helping you if
they want video of something like yeah
that's that's fine you know if someone
wants a video but for the most part
people wouldn't even abuse it anyways
because it's like kind of like it's a
social event like you want to be there
with your team you want to watch other
people lift you want to kind of cheer
them on and stuff like that
but you know I actually was just talking
about this yesterday I don't know if do
you know who Michelle what Andra is know
so she was a Games athlete I think she's
been to six games and now she's a coach
and she's coached she coaches patrickv
Ellner she coached Laura Horvath she's
she's a really really smart person
generally awesome and we were talking
about the differences when she was a
crossfitter and then when she went to
compete in weightlifting
and she remembers feeling a lot better
when she was lifting heavy while she was
a crossfitter which is interesting and I
think I know why and that's because
CrossFitters have that they can
alleviate the pressure from a certain
lift their fear of snatching heavy or
clean and jerking heavy and fear of
failure any of that is just not there
why even when they sweep because it's
imbedded in their sport why would you
care about a maximum snatch when you
have 13 other things that you have to do
like yeah you want to do the best you
can but this is not your identity this
is not who you are and when they switch
to competitive weightlifting that still
stays with them they're like oh it's my
first meet I'm just gonna have fun now
that's my second meet you know this I
will need them weightlifting for
officialy for a year now and I just keep
peeing all that stuff and that's a great
great mentality because they're
basically they're forgetting the things
that aren't that are outside of their
control they're they're completely
taking them out of you know out of the
situation and a lot of weight lifters
lose sight of that when they start
training and so there's there's this
line and we talk about this a lot me and
my coach max's is having this line of
expectations and standards so if you
expect a lot right and you have decently
high standards it's not always the best
having low expectations but incredibly
high standards is usually going to bid
you the best result for them most of the
for most of the time especially when
you're training it's challenging so when
you're passionate about something right
you know like you want to do well you
want to do yes everyone that's listening
that's despite expectations the word
itself expect why do we go about life
expecting anything X
fact like that's a stupid word that's
silly you're not you nothing is deserved
nothing is expected you just have to do
the best you can and do better than you
did before and at least try to do better
I think that is the only expectation is
that you will give your best effort when
you expect a certain result you either
get that result and there you go your
life is over or you get below that
result and everything sucks either way
everything sucks right it's being
process oriented versus goal oriented
okay but what we were talking about a
very interesting aspect is that the best
the elite elite elite like the Matt
Fraser's or the Michael Phelps those are
the ones that have high expectations and
high standards and they don't always
have the the best mental health because
of it couldn't agree more man there's a
bunch of people who I think aren't happy
I actually think my freighter is I think
he has he's just built to be a high
performer but a lot of time there's a
price that you need to pay I did a video
on this recently talking about you can't
just take part of someone's life you
have to take the whole so people look at
Elon Musk or [ __ ] Matt Fraser for
instance or you know Tiger Woods amazing
example actually Tiger Woods like you
look at Tiger Woods twenty years ago and
you got oh my god this guy's like worth
millions of dollars sponsored by Nike
best golfer on the planet child prodigy
this any other but if you find out about
Tiger especially if you read stillness
is the key by Ryan holiday he's got some
amazing research in that about Tiger and
that his dad is dad abused him as a
child
young golf like it was golf abuse but it
was absolutely 100% especially in
today's society would be considered
abuse he even had a safe word there had
a safe word Tiger Woods and his dad had
a safe word and the safe word was enough
and he never once said it they called it
they referred to it as the e word like
that it's crazy the hair stand up on the
back of my neck I know yeah yeah what
they had a safe word for when Tiger was
like that you've getting push you're
pushing me too hard here and like he
used to say that used to call him he
used to call his own son the n-word
who's like this is why you're a useless
and this is why this this is why that
like and you think okay you see Tiger
Woods you see the product at the end of
this we don't realize what he's had to
sacrifice all of the things that the
baggage that he carries with him that go
along with that
I remember in chasing excellence by Ben
Bertrand is this story about Matt Fraser
used to be a thinker engineer mechanic
yeah we went to the same College no way
yeah universities University that's how
yeah that's what people in the UK call
it university yes correct
as opposed I mean it is a university but
in America we we can say anything as a
college but yes go on
and there was a story he was revising at
night but for his engineering exam thing
and he wasn't letting himself leave the
library until he could recite this
entire chapter verbatim and then he
would get toward the end and would mess
up and then he'd go right just start
again I was like 5 a.m. and he finally
did it and let himself leave and he
think like the byproduct of that is you
have someone who is so particular about
the performance so incredibly precise
with what it is that they want but
what's the price that you have to pay
for that like yeah can Matt Fraser ever
go to bed without the room being made or
without putting his shorts away or can
he ever go on holiday without having a
minute-by-minute plan I don't know if
these are particular examples and
they're obviously not existential
threats but you can imagine if you start
to create more of a pathological
psychological profile of that there can
be some some fairly painful side effects
that come with this yeah it's did their
whole wanting to like I think if you
want to do better and you want to
improve low expectations high standards
if you want to be the absolute best you
have to almost tease yourself you almost
have to make fun of yourself you have to
make yourself depressed you have to make
yourself sad you have to make yourself
fearful you have to make yourself scared
those are not good health qualities you
should never do that if you want to live
a healthy safe happy life right but
that's not what these people want they
want to [ __ ] win that's like I would
never ever say to Matt Fraser you know
lo X well low expectations high
standards but I would say to 99.9% of
everyone in the world who wants to
improve at what they're doing low
expectations high standards they're
wanting to win is like a curse it's like
a horrible horrible thing and sometimes
you'll see a an athlete who's actually
so naturally gifted that they won't even
need to have that toxic of a mindset and
that's about the rarest of rare you know
who I think might have the patrickv ulna
upon looking from the outside and I
think he may do well you know again you
could never ever know because you're not
in Patrick felinors brain it's like we
we don't even know we don't know the
first thing about Matt Fraser we don't
live with him you know you know it's
like we don't know anyone
no one knows anyone's story or they
encounters that they have you can only
judge them based off of what well not to
use to tell you yeah and even then it's
like it's not even a fraction it's a
it's a blink of what they actually are
as a human and what they you know they
can tell you these things and interviews
and I'm not saying that these people are
hiding bad things I'm saying this
because I would hope that no one would
judge me for who I am or the type of
person I am or say that yeah you know
Zak isn't struggling or he is struggling
they wouldn't be able to tell those
things based off of the tiny little blip
of information they're given I on the
outside yet you know it does look like
Patrick Milner looks like the type of
guy who is just excels and has a good
mentality but you don't know the torment
that he gives himself
before he goes to sleep that's it I mean
that's things like that that's what he
knows that's what the the ultimate
leveler I think for everyone and this I
use this example with Elon Musk a lot
it's like everyone thinks Elon Musk
unbelievable PayPal mafia Tesla send him
[ __ ] people to Mars we're gonna
colonize the planet we're gonna do all
this sort of stuff I'd love to be him
he's just this super genius polymath
with billions of dollars and and right
Anna coolest [ __ ] company and if he
wants to create ventilators in a day
he'll do it because he's got the
productivity and all this stuff but you
don't know what the inside of Elon
Musk's head is like when he goes to
sleep on it exactly you don't know the
torment you're the one you know that's
my buddy just always would say to me it
would be like you're the one inside your
head you know it's it's as simple as a
voice in your head taunting you or you
know like that is not healthy like most
people you would try to eliminate that
voice of negativity or or whatever it is
that's not making you feel good we want
to feel good right but to some of these
people that voice is what fires them up
and that is not a good thing and that
doesn't make them a good person we have
a lot we have this this way of trying to
fixate patterns on people and we will
make assumptions to make ourselves feel
better
at any cost assumptions that have
absolutely zero basis in science or
basis in the real world well like this
person can't cheat he's a good person
well those are two different things
those are two different things
do you understand this person can't take
drugs
he's a I've seen him he's a good guy
what why those are not those you know
you can't say the grass is green because
the sky is blue or whatever that's not
how that works but we always want to
make patterns like that because it's
like that's a struggle of human
consciousness we're always trying to
find how we can make sense of this world
is his why I thought this has touched on
something I talk about a lot that we
think in archetypes so we have these
cultural memes that we're fed especially
when we're young and then we try and
swap people into these archetypes the
hero the maid and the villain the
redeemed the hopeless case you know the
nerd the the strong alpha the silent guy
you know all of these different things
and we try and slot people into this
part of it is because we're lazy and
it's because we don't want to have to do
the work to work out what hang on Zack's
like got a bit of this but he's also got
like a bit of that in him and a little
bit of this and that doesn't read these
two things don't really fit so I'm kind
of gonna forget about that and I'll just
have him as the Alpina mister that guy
you know it's like whatever the majority
of your personality makeup is we'll just
use that the best stories the best films
are the ones that question that but the
best ones by far who do we root for
who's good who's bad what is good and
what is bad what is morality what is
immoral now those are the best stories
and it's really funny because in in
Hollywood like people still they're like
what's his thing
like what what's his archetype they see
the hero of this story it's like why are
we still why is that everyone's go-to
even though we know the best stories are
the ones that question those things
think about like something as simple as
like the Joker that just came out are we
on Arthur flex side or are we not art
you know who's good who's bad is Murray
bad is very good we don't people like
that that sort of stuff it it causes
pain in people
I left that movie theater and I [ __ ] you
not have looked around I remember
hearing conversations of girls and and
guys everyone being like that [ __ ]
sucked that movie sucked
that movie was depressing I'd I'm
so pissed I went and saw that movie I
walked out of that movie theater being
like that was one of the best movies
I've ever sat down and watch ever you
know because I when I go to something
like that I want it
it's helps it's an exercise to question
my surroundings to question my world
when we want to go to the movie theater
and hold up a big foam finger and get
our popcorn and you know cheer on Vin
Diesel and The Fast and the Furious guys
like that's fine but what happens is
that sort of mindset carries over into
all things culture we want to deliver an
ideology we want to deliver a subset of
things where we can fit people all the
goddamn time and it runs it runs amok it
kind of it doesn't allow for nuance that
is my channel is based off of nuance
even though it's a simple thing where
all I talk about is this match in the
clean injure right if that's it then I
should have ended my channel two years
ago if it's just about those two things
there's no nuance there but that is the
goal of my style of coaching my style of
everything is to play with what is what
is the answer
nuance nuance nuance always in between
the lines always examining what has
prior what what people have done what
people have thought and examine what I
have done and what I have thought and
experiences I've had if we're not doing
things like that then we're just gonna
keep in this cyclical [ __ ] narrative
this structure that's always gonna
repeat itself over and over and over
again that it's in in all honesty that
was all I did I
here is my structure if anyone is
listening to how I made my youtube
channel what it is instead of saying
here's how you do this match you do the
snatch like this you do this you do this
you do that thank you for watching
I was saying when you learn this thing
it's likely that this will happen and
it's likely that you'll be told to do
this what I have found through my own
experimentation is that either of those
could work if done like this or this or
this do you see the the variance in that
that right there it has like you know
offshoots of different routes you can go
different things I want to empower the
viewer not tell them what to do so I
continually will try to do that when
when I when someone wants me to to do a
video on programming I think what is the
issue actually I don't want to I don't
want to write a program and say do this
I want to know what it is that most
people do wrong and I want to fix it or
or offer suggestions on how you can fix
it and that's it and then and honest to
god I know I just went on like a huge
rant but that that is the biggest
without question part of my success and
I'm sure as far as your podcast goes
that's what you want to do too you want
to live in the nuance so I mean right
man that's literally that's what
interests me it's the reason that I have
these conversations you know and I say
I've said it million times I'm gonna say
again if you are not having a
conversation with a friend about Kant's
concept that you are interested in for
at least half an hour a week where your
phones are outside of the room then you
are missing out on the opportunity to
develop yourself I think it's like oh
well I need to do my yoga this week or I
need to do my mobility today or I need
to go for a walk I need to get my 10,000
steps once a week you need to have a
conversation with a friend that's not
distracted by other things because it
sharpens your skills it improves the
precision of your thoughts improves your
ability to articulate things I it could
be with yourself men like well you could
record a monologue you could everyone's
got a phone I mean I definitely talked
to myself for sure like there's no
question and I know that might sound
weird or whatever but I sometimes I'll
be walking the dogs and I'll just think
out loud sometimes I'll just start
talking and it looks like I have
schizophrenia but but realistic
like III couldn't agree more with you
know did you ever see the documentary on
Avicii yes that the one on Netflix yeah
okay so there's the part where he says
he's really interested in this article
or maybe this study that's that talks
about the type of introverts there are
and he's like I'm kind of what you would
call an extroverted introvert or
something like that and he's like I am
NOT interested in going out and partying
but I am very interested in being social
and sharing ideas with people and very
deep meaningful discussion so in that
sense being very sociable does not mean
being an extrovert wanting to share
ideas and wanting to talk about
philosophy talk about deeper things that
is an inherently you know it could be
called an introverted thing even though
it involves other people I believe that
I kind of fit into something like that
and ultimately you can see during this
documentary he wants that the whole time
you know when you have when you're that
famous and making that much money for
other people those other people are
going to treat you like a product there
because they make money off of you so at
no point in any time did anyone stop to
talk politics with the man and that's
all he wanted to do talk politics talk
religion talk philosophy you know my
wife her parents and their friends would
get together and they would talk about
politics religion and philosophy the
three things that at the dinner table
with friends you are not supposed to
talk about right they would have all of
their friends come over and those are
the three things that they would talk
about because they it's like what are we
then if we're just a system of
[ __ ] that we just regurgitate to
each other right I totally agree at
least a half hour a week that's nothing
man it's not a way to program it in so
here's another one for you this is
something you may not have heard of
before
George McGill who is the highest ever
played episode he's just a mate just an
essentially nobody highest ever played
episode more than Robert Greene more
than Aubrey Marcus more than Dave Castro
or Dan Bailey Wow and it's just a
conversation between me and him and he
brings up this idea which is called high
agency he says it's the single most
useful skill the most powerful skill in
the 21st century to conversation about
mental models and high agencies one of
them high agency is a ability for a
person to enact change as they see fit
within the world and the way to work out
who your friend with high agency or the
highest agency friend that you have is
is to do this mental exercise I'm gonna
get you to do it now and I want to hear
your answer yeah so imagine that you are
put into a foreign jail let's say South
America you're put in South America jail
somewhere Panama somewhere proper now
you can get [ __ ] up and you have to
get out in 24 hours who do you call
you can calm one friend who's the person
that you call
it's it's definitely gonna be the person
that is the most communicative right the
most dependable person well think about
think about what they're going to be
able to do they they're not going to
need anyone else they're going to have
incredible solidarity they're gonna be
able to think laterally orthogonal e
they're gonna be able to as you say
they're going to manipulate things in
terms of a social aspect they're going
to be likable they're gonna be able to
think outside of the box you know all of
these different all these different
things and write a crucial the crucial
thing is they do all of that in motion
so it's not that they can abstractly
think about what they would do it's the
ability of someone because there's tons
of people that have great ideas there's
many people have you heard that's our
I'd love to start a YouTube like doing
video of people as Amana there are
combinations I love listening to podcast
it's like put it into motion
yeah the actionable person to is what
what matters who'd personally gets [ __ ]
done
who would you ring probably my buddy
Augie he's one of my longest and best
friends he would answer and you know he
would get a plan together in action like
almost immediately for sure you know for
sure no question and I think you know
that's it's interesting you say that my
coach max he always says ideas are
meaningless you know ideas are
absolutely meaningless it's the it's the
what am I thinking what what kind of
phrase am I thinking about
it's the actionable capitalization No
[Music]
it's he always uses this as an example
uber as an idea is a great idea but
supposedly and I don't know if this is
completely true still it's losing money
as a company
yeah is that true yeah I think so right
so it's not a good company it's not I'm
out I'll be the first person to say that
if you're losing money you're not a good
company right does that REITs idea bad
company yes
okay so his thing that Mac says is if
you could you would that's it if you
could do it wouldn't you do it if you
can sit there and criticize someone on
the way that they're doing something
that would mean that you could do it and
if you could do it wouldn't you [ __ ]
do it
that's a Reno right that's a really
really good way to put it you know I'm
sure this as simple as it gets like a
lot of people I did an episode with dr.
David Sinclair Harvard Medical School
one of the 50 most influential health
professionals on the planet immediately
after Rogen had him and then I had him
I'm just like wow I'm still just some
guy but I was even less of some guy a
year ago year-and-a-half go anyway um
and I start getting all of these things
like why didn't you ask him questions
about this why didn't you chase him up
on the fact that he's doing I'm like why
don't you ask him on your podcast yeah
oh right you don't have one yeah so
here's okay here's another one and again
I max max ADA I don't know if you know
who he is
he's a pretty famous American
weightlifting coach everyone should
check him out but he's definitely a big
influence on me and he there's three
category three criteria for what makes
you a good weightlifting coach is what
have you done yourself
what have you done with others and what
sort of education have you taken on to
make yourself better these are things
that are always moving you will never be
a good coach in the sense that you can't
get better so you people can think of
you being good as relative to other
people or relative to other things but
you'll never be a good solidified coach
you always have to be evolving but what
have you done can mean what
what have you lifted and from what point
have you lifted this and lifted that so
your improvement over this amount of
time have you can you can you show it to
me
skin in the game yes with others now
this is a broader one but again you
could always think you have taken
athlete a and you have brought them
where show me exactly where the [ __ ] you
did that where did that athlete get
better and I need to see it okay or what
coach have you taken under your wing
what sort who can vouch for you who can
I talk to and say you know what that's a
[ __ ] good coach who can do that
that's it's your relationship with
others and the final one is education
what are you currently doing to be a
better coach through things that aren't
maybe lifting related to be a better
person to be a better you know father
husband you know boyfriend whatever it
is what are you doing how are you
educating yourself it could be you know
you you go and you find a mentor you you
go and you visit someone and you have a
podcast with them like those are
educational moments those are things for
growth and if you can't provide me with
those three things in any light you are
not you are not doing a good job of
proving yourself in whatever field that
is what have you done what have you done
with others and what the [ __ ] is your
education or how are you educating
yourself and some people all say what
have you done and they'll be like I
don't have anything yeah okay so why are
we having this discussion it random
internet commenter who thinks they know
[ __ ] better you know this is another
thing too is the people that are the
quickest to talk [ __ ] to me or talk
about me or about anyone are the last
people to be doing it themselves I when
I go to these weightlifting meets I see
the same coaches the same lifters at
every single one of them and I'm so
happy to see them
they're always there and the people that
that comment that talk [ __ ] that create
the most noise are never there
ever
it's as simple as that show up just show
up just show up be a part of it if you
want to fix it that you know it's like
it's like in any Americans and I'm sure
people from the UK love complaining
about politics on their Facebook or
whatever they put they'll never ever do
anything about it
ever ever ever ever you know it's just
it's it's [ __ ] like that is is
mind-boggling to me I think it becomes
binocularly it becomes particularly
irritating to somebody like yourself up
you know anyone that's listening it
doesn't you've been [ __ ] children of
the 21st century with our newfangled
youtubes and Instagram podcast profiles
and all this [ __ ] like it doesn't matter
about that but there's people that are
listening who have high agency that are
just great mums great brothers great you
know yes employees get great managers
great directors of companies whatever it
might be that there's still people that
have that high agency that still are in
motion right they're doing stuff but
you're right the it's the the same
people who always tend to comment but
don't ever put it into action and
there's something particularly
triggering about that in a way it's
weakness but it's it's it makes you feel
you it's gobsmacked you like that guy
that guy said that thing that works yeah
I said what how do you how did he say it
you know even still it's like even still
I try to avoid even like the simplicity
of getting upset with a commenter what I
like to know is the you look at the huge
picture around that why are they
commenting and what are they not doing
what is what is the process that we are
in as a society that allows this type of
[ __ ] you know because like you said
there's a lot of people out there
listening who are [ __ ] awesome people
and when I see someone who kicks ass as
a father who kicks or kicks ass as a
mother
brother just kicks ass as a [ __ ]
person and doesn't have any followers or
anything like that like crazy going on
they're just good people like I have
more respect for them than anyone that
if there's no separation I don't give a
[ __ ] who you are if you can prove to me
those things like I love you as a person
and I will always and forever the person
though that like the first thing they
think about is complaining with no
action that is like you said in
gobsmacked I don't know that's kind of a
non-american term you Joe hits the floor
yeah yeah I mean you're that is the [ __ ]
that is insane to me and it's way way
too common like okay you post you post
something the first thing I want to
think about is what's a negative comment
I can put to that what's wrong about
this and I'm gonna post it immediately
i I I don't think except for Brian rose
from London real who looks like a card
out of water and I dislike intensely
except for him I I don't think I've ever
said anything bad about anyone on the
Internet I'm a vendetta for Brian Rose
aside like that's it and I don't
understand people who go out of their
way to say anything bad like let's say
that you put up let's say your next
video should be because you wouldn't you
wouldn't but let's something you'll know
it unless you had anything in the game
if you have I can shed skin in the game
you wouldn't [ __ ] do it but let's say
that your next video sucks I'm sure it
won't but let's say that your next video
sucks I'm Wes don't be so sure don't be
so sure and I'm like um I'm not gonna
cut even if whether I know you or
whether I don't I'm not gonna comment
and say this video [ __ ] I might comment
and say hey man um like get what you're
trying to do here but really don't think
this is your best work perhaps you shoe
perhaps this would be a real cool way to
to try and redo this and you'd read and
go that would hit you a lot harder it's
weirdly like if someone messages and
sends me something where they tell me
the thing that I know that was
yes I'm going to look for a nuanced
approach but I've never gone out of my
way I don't want to do that I don't want
to I don't want to just waste my time
having random internet arguments with
stranger people you know I'm looking at
my my phone here because I want to point
out one of one of these people let's
give them a shower yeah you know because
this is the damage that people do
especially with this you know with the
kovat 19 thing there's a lot of [ __ ]
damage that can be done with shitty
commenting a lot and there's no
punishment for it there's no being held
accountable so this guy goes I basically
when [ __ ] really started hitting the fan
with the virus I basically was like hey
guys you know it sucks the gym is shut
down and it sucks a lot for us for the
people who the gym is a big part of
their identity like it I I do think it's
a big deal that the gyms are shut down
most people are like that gym you know
it's just a play it's like for me that's
my life like I spent so much time in
there it is a big deal
but we have to do these things for
public safety you know that's it that's
your social you know you your
accountability as a person in society
this guy goes in my opinion the
statement that's shutting down gyms is
necessary for safety is one of the most
asinine absurdities I can recall in
regard to the overall risk this is one
of the most mild viruses in centuries
really people wake up quit mindlessly
believing everything you're told and
check the facts this was three weeks ago
okay well we'll get to how idiotic that
is I just responded I said really one of
the most asinine absurdities you can
recall speaking in hyperbole against
something you believe is hyperbolic is
oh so funny to me right so using
hyperbole to speaking in something hyper
and then he goes he responds
you've been alive long enough to
remember several outbreak breaks through
the years which one was less dangerous
which one had a lower mortality rate how
many gyms do you remember closed for
that outbreak the answer to all of them
is none I love your content but that
statement is but making that sorry I'm
glad you're gonna continue making it but
that statement to placate to be
politically correct or whatever is in my
opinion asinine absurd absurdity now
mind you this was three weeks ago and I
already knew this guy was a total
[ __ ] yesterday yesterday the amount
of people that have died in in the US
alone from Kovan nineteen surpassed an
entire year of swine flu which is the
next one right so directly here as a
more violent virus right this is a very
violent virus like it and that's not to
make people panic but it is what it
[ __ ] is we're not doing this because
of some conspiracy theory right and his
thing was he said back he goes he's like
you're right it's officially more
dangerous than swine flu I stand
corrected given the overall
ineffectiveness of our attempts to
flatten the curve do you still believe
in that mandatory shutting down of gyms
was necessary for safety and I just
simply said yes and he goes fair enough
right so maybe he conceded my not to
read that is a rarity humid by Internet
but three weeks ago is when we needed
[ __ ] [ __ ] faces like that to not say
[ __ ] like that three weeks ago was when
it mattered the that's the point of this
disease is that it takes time to develop
you can be asymptomatic first a long
period of time right so so three weeks
ago when people are like this is
[ __ ] this is an asinine absurdity
and then now they're like you know what
I was wrong it's like know that you
can't do that your words mean things
if someone read that comment I know that
this is crazy and it probably didn't
happen but if someone read that it was
like you know what yeah [ __ ] it and they
by chance
we're an ace in
Domanick carrier and they brought the
virus somewhere else that is how the
that's how words can affect culture and
not being held accountable to anything
you say
not being held actionable to the words
that you say is the ultimate plague it
plagues us as a society so when someone
sees something and the immediate thought
is I'm going to complain about it but
I'm not gonna do a goddamn thing to
change it they are the problem not the
solution always man I couldn't agree
more there's a blog post that I keep on
referencing it's got the worst click
Beatty title by David Wong but it's had
like 14 million hits blog post 14
million hits and it's called 6 harsh
truths that will make you a better
person
and essentially one of them the main one
is that you are what you produce nothing
else so he's talking about as a good
example he's saying um you're a single
guy who complains maybe about not
getting girls and this this archetype
could be used for anything I am of this
that doesn't get this and you say well I
don't really understand because I'm
really nice and I'm kind and I'm caring
and I I turn up on time and I always
hold the door open for her and I do this
and I do that and they're like right so
[ __ ] what like there is a guy that's
just the entry price that you pay to be
a good human to get in the game there is
a guy out there who has all of the
things that you've just described and he
can play the [ __ ] guitar yep and
you're like okay you can play the guitar
and that that's stuck with me because it
it gets us away from this cycle the the
recycling of information the recycling
of existing talents and skills routines
mindsets all of the things that we do
and trying to break that wheel as can
obviously breaking it in the correct
direction as opposed to making it worse
because you can break your habits and
and replace them with worse ones but
trying to do that you know like that's
the the learning element of your the
learning in the personal element of your
weight lifting trio and then you've got
the transcendent element which is the
one that's in the middle which is to do
with making other people better that's
our end so yeah
so I I don't know I think III think that
there's a lot there's an awful lot there
and we knowing just knowing the lowest
common denominator so people always talk
about hard work and I'm someone who
questions that idea of hard work because
hard work is relative and a lot of times
hard work is the lowest common
denominator right if smart work talent
those are things that are needed you
know hard work so here's a good example
I can get to the gym I'm gonna work the
I'm gonna [ __ ] work harder than
anyone well if I'm not smart about it
that hard work doesn't mean [ __ ] I take
a maximum back squat and unrack it and
say I'm gonna back squat this tell me
you're not working hard it's impossible
to not work hard when you're back
squatting it's impossible you put it you
put all the weight you can on your back
and you're like [ __ ] this is heavy
that's hard work but it's not going to
make you better
you know unless you know what you're
doing with it
so it's this culture of hard work wins
hard work wins it's like no that's not
it's not ever the case that's the lowest
common denominator that's the price the
entry price you have to pay to get
through you know there's someone that's
working hard and is really good at the
guitar you know and they're recovering
and the nutrition's right and they're
helping to transcend what they do by
bringing other people up which then
brings their game up even further under
doing the continuous professional
development and learning it man I get it
look at sake I feel that we could go on
for four all night man I'm gonna have to
get you one again so we can keep this
conversation going but look tell and
tell everyone why they can go whether
should had to check you out so first and
foremost YouTube channel just search Zak
za CK telander te la nder and then if
you you want to follow me on instagram
coach underscore ZT i also have $1
program for for weightlifting so I have
$1 programming yeah on my patreon
patreon comm slashes AK telander and you
know if you want to start weightlifting
you can just click one of those programs
download it and there you go it also
just supports me and my endeavors you
know I the money from that patreon to go
like fly to meets I it was cool like my
last patreon check paid for my going to
the Arnold and paying for all of my
expenses there to coach to literally
just for my job so it was it was really
awesome that's that's it awesome I love
it everything will be linked in the show
notes below of course if you've enjoyed
this episode you know what to do go and
head on Zach's channel give him some
give him some love maybe try and find
that comment of someone who doesn't know
what they're talking about to do with
coronavirus like share and subscribe if
you've enjoyed this episode give me a
message wherever you follow me but for
now Zach man thank you so much yeah
thanks for having me man
[Music]
you